son muchas las personas que han acudido
hasta aquí el estadio de Vila belmirro
desde las diez de la mañana y eso a
pesar de que la fila es muy larga el
tiempo de espera para llegar hasta el
férretro de Pelé es de más de dos horas
hemos visto a familias enteras personas
de todas las edades incluso a muchos
jóvenes y niños que han desafiado el
calor intenso que hace aquí en Santos
para despedirse del rey del fútbol
muchos llevan la camisa con el número 10
la misma que usaba Pelé se oyen aplausos
y ovaciones la emoción está a flor de
piel aquí varias personas comparan este
Velorio con el de la reina de Inglaterra
porque dicen aquí en Brasil también se
ha muerto un rey entre las
personalidades que han pasado hoy por
Vila belmiro destaca el presidente de la
FIFA el de la selección brasileña y
también el padre del jugador Neymar en
todo el estadio hay muchas imágenes del
Astro del fútbol que en este país tan
dividido política se ha convertido un
poco en un símbolo de Unión también se
escuchan canciones del propio Pelé que
en su vida fue cantor y compositor
Mañana es el día del entierro y está
previsto que llegue desde Brasilia el
nuevo presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva antes el féretro saldrá en
procesión por la ciudad de santos y
pasar adelante de la casa de Doña
Celeste la madre de Pelé que cumplió 100
años el día en que arrancó el mundial de
Qatar